Film Courage: So with all the trials and tribulations
with DRIFTER and your goal to make a film
before age 30, the film eventually ended up
on Netflix?
Chris von Hoffmann, horror writer/director:
It was a pretty quick turnaround which was
quite shocking.
The whole first quarter of 2017 of last year
was pretty hectic because I was in the thickness
of prepping MONSTER PARTY, meeting with all
these actors for that and then DRIFTER was
screening at UCLA and it finally had its theatrical
run at this little arthouse theater in Hollywood.
And then it went to iTunes and Amazon and
all that afterwards and then once we were
filming MONSTER PARTY, it went to Netflix
in May of last year.
So no one had any more excuses to not watch
the movie.
Then everyone started to watch it.
It helped so much that it went to Netflix
and then when it goes to Netflix, you start
to learn about the darkness of the Internet,
trolls and everyone has an opinion and everyone
loves to comment.
At a certain point they all start saying the
same thing and there is no point responding
to anyone of them.
I just don’t respond to anyone if they’re
obnoxious with comments, it’s like you just
didn’t get the movie.
But it definitely helped a lot and then there
were people who totally loved it and totally
got what the movie was.
I got some very nice messages from people
and some not-so-nice messages from people.
But if you’re going to make movies you’ve
got to be thick-skinned, you’ve just got
to embrace it but it was a very interesting
time.
I just wasn’t expecting the movie to get
as much exposure as it did.
I thought it was going to get a small distribution
and just move on.
But then when The Hollywood Reporter is writing
about it and IndieWire is writing about it
and then it’s getting released all over
the world I’m like “Well…there you are!”
And every decision you made is all up there
to watch.
But I don’t regret anything.
At the time that was exactly the movie I wanted
to make.
I just wanted to push the soundtrack, push
all that stuff, must maximize the aesthetic
where you’ve got to pull back for later
movies.
With MONSTER PARTY it’s a similar kind of
genre (hybrid storytelling), it’s still
a very different movie at the same time.
All the mistakes that I learned on that movie
(that people had no problem telling me about),
I feel like I learned a lot from.
I always read a handful of bad reviews, you
just want to know what bothers people, what
doesn’t work for people and just fix that
stuff.
Because with MONSTER PARTY we spent a year
on the script.
I wanted to make sure that it was an improvement,
if anything else, I just wanted to make sure
it was an improvement and I feel like it is.
Film Courage: It’s interesting because I
was watching an interview with Margaret Atwood,
it was a BBC documentary or something.
And she was talking about her first book (it
blew out the numbers that they had first projected)
and someone gave her the advice of (and he
just looked at her) “Now they can shoot
at you.”
Especially plus too [her critics asked], “Where
does this darkness come from?
You must have gone through these things?”
[Her response] “No, this is just what I
write about.
You don’t have to have experienced them
to go to that level of darkness.”
So she talked about this as well [harsh criticism].
Did you think that DRIFTER was going to get
to that level when you were making it or you
needed to fulfill a goal for yourself?
Chris: I needed to fulfill a goal and I had
no idea it was going to get the kind of exposure
it got.
It was great in the long run.
I mean it did everything I needed it to do.
I had no regrets about any of it.
If there is just one regret, I wish we spent
more time on the screenplay, that I wasn’t
so unbelievably…I’m a very antsy kind
of person.
But now I’ve grown so much as a filmmaker
after that and I changed a lot of how I want
to approach things.
And I’ve grown to actually love writing
now and I want to spend a lot of time on the
screenplay.
With DRIFTER I think I was just at the point…I
was concerned with visual construction and
composition and aesthetic and style because
that movie is all about style.
It’s all about the mood and atmosphere and
the music.
There is really nothing much more to it.
That’s very much what it’s about.
It’s like a music video or something.
And at that time, that was the kind of movie
I wanted to make.
And now I am much more interested in proper
character development, proper narrative.
Because DRIFTER was a very particular kind
of movie.
Even my shorts are nothing like that movie
at all.
It was like let me just get this ultimate,
nostalgic movie out of my system and just
purge myself, chock full of all this stuff
I’ve always wanted to do.
The things that I’ve loved growing up, all
these obscurities and push everything to the
max from beginning to end and just see where
it lands.
It was a very polarizing movie when it came
out.
I thought it was a very interesting reaction
that movie got because I was like “Really?
It was just such a tiny little movie?”
It generated a very polarizing emotion from
people.
A lot of people took it very personally they
way they were reacting to it.
As long as they react, I don’t care if they
love it or hate it, I just want them to react
to it and have an opinion about it whether
it’s good or not.
Because if you believe the good reviews, you
have to believe the bad reviews.
At a certain point it all just becomes moot.
They are all helpful but you should let reviews…the
good reviews don’t matter and the bad reviews
don’t matter in the grand scheme of things.
But I think it is good to just read them a
little bit.
Not be so distant from them because I think
they are taking the time to write about your
movie and they might be crapping all over
it but they are taking the time to write about
it.
At the time Hollywood Reporter gave a review
I was like “Wow!
This is a tough, tough business.”
Because they gave a review that was not the
best and they’re not wrong, that’s how
they feel.
Even when they are criticizing it, they are
still complimenting it inside of those criticism
because I think a lot of people thought it
was a much bigger movie.
I don’t think it being a small movie should
ever dictate how harsh you are going to be
on something, it’s still just the movie
itself.
But it’s just I do think some people thought
it was a really dark movie and it just wasn’t
at all, it was peanuts.
I thought it was kind of funny that they were
thinking it was almost like a backhanded compliment.
I think embrace the bad reviews, embrace all
that stuff because it’s just all part of
making movies.
Film Courage: How did you get a distribution
deal?
Chris: My cinematographer had come across
a sales agent at SXSW in early 2015.
He’d asked him if he had any movies he was
working on, horror films and this was one
that we were in soft prep for and then I met
with him right before we were about to shoot
and he switched over to a different company
(a sales agency company) and he kept in touch
on the movie.
I was sending him all these stills and he
came to set a couple of times and then we
cut a trailer for the American Film Market
in 2015, which was very much as commercial
of a trailer as we can make it, just very
much like “Straightforward, action, thriller,
cannibal movie.”
And actually our movie is not that at all.
It has all that stuff in it but it’s a weird
movie.
So we make a trailer to show at AFM and I
get buyers interested and there were a couple
of distributors that he was constantly talking
to for awhile while we were editing the film.
I hated showing work-in-progress versions
of the movie because I was like “No one
is going to truly be able to experience this
movie until it’s mixed.”
It’s just a very specific hybrid, tonal,
poem, kind of like wacked out experience and
the soundtrack is so paramount for this movie.
I just need to finish the movie before you
see what this thing.
And I think that about almost everything,
I never think the movie is good until it’s
finished (I just don’t) and when I say finished
I mean mixed, I think mixing is like the temple
for the movie and I think people underestimate
that a lot, just adjusting volumes but I think
it’s really much more than that.
All little nuances really dictate the experience.
He was really loyal to the film and a couple
months after we finished the movie in April
2016.
We had a little friends and family screening
and couple months later.
We were able to lock in the US distributor.
Then learning all about the deliverables,
I remember getting the document and it gives
you a migraine, your brain starts hurting
reading all these things.
You’re just like “This is a nightmare.
But then you show it to your sound mixer and
editor and your assistant editor and they
understand it much more clear.
It’s just so overly-technical the way it’s
described and it’s so many things I’ve
got
to send.
They ended up releasing the movie in February
2017.
Australia released the film first, around
Halloween of 2016 (so it was on DVD out there)
and then the following Spring it started to
snowball and go to the US, Canada and Germany
and all these different places.
Seeing all the fake posters that Germany made,
some were awesome actually but some were like…I
see them and it’s good artwork but…it’s
so unbelievably…I see what you’re doing
but it’s so not what this movie is at all.
I remember one poster said “The Book of
Eli meets whatever…”
It’s like “Oh, don’t.”
This movie is…it’s a weird acid trip,
David Lynchian kind of thing.
It has cool action stuff but it’s not like
this movie that you’re describing to people.
I though that was kind of funny.
Some people when they see the movie are like
“What the…?”
I think that’s kind of fun though when people
are marketed something and like when DRIVE
came out everyone was like “FAST AND THE
FURIOUS!”
And some people were saying “What is this
movie?”
But I think that’s a nice surprise though
sometimes.